hola bienvenidos a migrante es el
programa semanal de france 24 sobre el
éxodo lo saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
el anuncio de la reapertura de las
fronteras en eeuu e ilusionó a miles de
emigrantes varados en el límite sur que
esperan una respuesta a sus solicitudes
de asilo sin embargo nada parece cambiar
para ellos muchos fueron devueltos a
méxico bajo el título 42 una norma que
se basa en la situación sanitaria por el
kobe 19 para avalar la expulsión de
extranjeros que llegaron de manera
irregular por el momento eeuu no se ha
pronunciado sobre la aceptación de
nuevos migrantes en su territorio
rodrigo se da no tiene más detalles de
lo que pasa en la frontera
una nueva vida es lo que miles de
emigrantes ven al otro lado de este paso
fronterizo en tijuana al norte de méxico
pues todos tenemos ganas de llegar para
eeuu ese es el único pensamiento que hay
osea llegaría a hacer oración todo el
tiempo en que vamos a llegar
a eeuu
pero pues no todos así como tristes como
desesperados es lo que se siente aquí en
este y otros campamentos en la frontera
de méxico con estados unidos viven más
de 1200 personas algunos esperaron hasta
19 meses por una noticia la reapertura
de la frontera con la relajación de las
restricciones por la pandemia el paso
terrestre reabrió finalmente el lunes 8
de noviembre pero nada cambió para los
habitantes de este campamento pues eeuu
no se ha pronunciado sobre la re
aceptación de migrantes la gente todavía
tiene una esperanza y tienen la fe de
que cualquier momento puede haber
nuevamente esa apertura de la ayuda que
estaba brindando el gobierno
estadounidense a la población que viene
buscando el asilo con la ayuda
humanitaria
entretanto una nueva caravana migrante
avanza por territorio mexicano el grupo
es cada vez menor con el paso de los
días cansados y temerosos de una guardia
nacional que mató a disparos a un
migrante cubano durante el tránsito
estamos tratando de llegar a la ciudad
de mexico y hemos visto que están
dispuestos a hasta derramar sangre hasta
800 personas habrían parado su marcha y
regularizado su situación gracias a
tarjetas de visitante entregadas por el
instituto nacional de inmigración de
méxico pero los que buscan una respuesta
de eeuu a sus solicitudes siguen sumando
días de espera
al comenzar su mandato el presidente joe
biden presentó un proyecto de ley de
reforma migratoria que beneficiaría a
unos 11 millones de indocumentados esa
reforma aún está pendiente y la promesa
de alejarse de las políticas impuestas
por el gobierno trump tampoco se ha
cumplido hay más coincidencias que
diferencias entre ambos gobiernos sobre
el tema migratorio se lo preguntamos a
thomas kennedy de la coalición de
inmigrantes de florida
forma que la administración habla de
inmigración es muy diferente a la lo que
vimos en la administración del trump
pero en política concreta creo que había
una continuación por ejemplo en la
frontera si éste se sigue usando el
título 42 que una política supuestamente
de salud pública aunque expertos como
anthony fauci han dicho que los
inmigrantes no son un gran vector del
contagio del cob y 19 pero es una
política que se usa para básicamente
negarle
a los refugiados a la gente que está
pidiendo asilo en los estados unidos- su
derecho internacional y nacional es
impedir ese estatus y hemos visto que es
miles y miles de inmigrantes refugiados
gente viendo asilo han sido rechazados
en la frontera y una gran parte son
inmigrantes raza negra particularmente
viniendo de haití entonces es algo que
lamentablemente él sigue sido una
continuación de las políticas
antimigrantes trompistas
ante este panorama y con una reforma
pendiente por trámite en el congreso lo
cierto es que la migración es un tema
que divide a los estadounidenses así
define guadalupe correa experta en temas
migratorios la política que el gobierno
de joe biden ha escrito durante nueve
meses de gobierno
en realidad no podríamos evaluar la
política migratoria
de byd en el presidente baile en este
momento catalogándola de buena o de mala
yo creo que el sistema migratorio
estadounidense es muy complicado y las
administraciones anteriores se han
enfrentado con esta gran división que
existe al interior del país con respecto
a la migración y a la politización del
tema porque es un tema que desde el
punto de vista electoral mueve muchos
intereses y mueve muchos sentimientos
entonces no podríamos colocar toda la
responsabilidad en una administración en
un presidente en realidad pues se han
mantenido muchas de las políticas que
se criticaron en la elección por parte
de esta administración en realidad
muchas de las promesas que hizo el
presidente el ahora presidente yo baiden
en campaña no se han cumplido en este
sentido para aquellos que que creyeron
al pie de la letra lo que se había
propuesto pues puede quedar bastante
bastante decepcionado pero desde el
punto de vista humano y esto es muy
importante él el presidente yo bailé la
administración del presidente de joe by
de la vicepresidenta kamala harris han
mantenido políticas que criticaron de
ser no humanas y de no considerar a las
personas y sus derechos para pedir asilo
mientras tanto la frontera sur de eeuu
refleja el desafío que tiene por delante
del gobierno de estadounidense para dar
respuesta a los que llevan en meses
varados en méxico un país que no es ni
el suyo ni al que quieren llegar hasta
aquí inmigrantes de france24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]